7,2% más este es el aumento del
presupuesto del ejército chino para 2023
un anuncio hecho durante la reunión de
la asamblea popular nacional que debe
reelegir al presidente por tercera vez
china quiere fortalecer su ejército para
competir con el de Estados Unidos su
presupuesto representará 225 mil
millones de dólares la segunda partida
militar más grande del mundo que queda
muy por detrás de la estadounidense en
800 mil millones de dólares
realmente necesitamos implementar la
voluntad de Jean pin de fortalecernos
militarmente nuestras fuerzas armadas
que tienen objetivos específicos para el
centenario del ejército Popular de
liberación deben trabajar para
fortalecer la gobernanza militar
consolidar los resultados de la defensa
nacional y acelerar nuestros proyectos
de desarrollo de defensa
en lo que respecta efectivo es el
ejército chino es el más grande del
mundo tiene dos millones de soldados
contra un millón cuatrocientos mil de
Estados Unidos 350 givas nucleares 15
veces menos que Estados Unidos pero más
que Francia y tres portaaviones contra
once de los estadounidenses la Marina
china ha crecido considerablemente hasta
convertirse en la primera flota del
mundo en cantidad Aunque sus barcos son
más pequeños y de menor alcance que los
estadounidenses una Marina que es hoy la
herramienta imprescindible de china en
su punto de mira hacia la vecina isla de
Taiwán que Beijing considera una
provincia Rebelde y con la que promete
dar pasos decididos para oponerse a un
eventual Independencia por otro lado la
fuerza de proyección del ejército chino
es muy limitada con una sola base
extranjera en yibutti cuando Washington
la tiene en todo el mundo